with fighting when it comes to the
figure figure figurero figuero figured
it out
jesus [__] christ figure it out huh
guy but a lot of people say differently
every episode it changes the name he's
switching the letters man the guy is
cheating and then letters man
but do you guys think you can do is it
possible for one of you to knock the
other one out or it's not possible you
think honestly after this after this
much experience
man
i don't know
because i mean
before
or reality i mean fidel was like
like you know oh thank you man
uh so before already
he was like knocking out every single
fighter
in the roster and he was doing a very
great job doing that
yeah but with me i mean
he
he hit me with
his best punches and
do you think either one of you can knock
the other do you think you can knock him
out like because you guys can obviously
you you can both
find a way to win
but is it possible i wonder because you
guys do i mean no i mean the possibility
is always there man you know talking
about myself
i know
i don't have that kind of power to knock
one people out with like cold i know
that you can work in the gym you know
you can work in your extension
conditioning you can work with your
explosivity and you can work with your
technique and your position oh yeah and
i try to to work within that like every
single time in the gym right but i know
i i don't bore with that [__]
superpower
like just engaging
that is like
that is amazing
um fidel born with that power
but i mean
i don't have that superpower but i have
another one yeah i have a nice chin man
yeah oh yeah
you got an extra chin huh yes i mean who
has it in your family a family member
has it too
i don't know because
my family doesn't have the history of
sports
wow they never play like soccer it's a
regular sport in mexico so they never
play soccer or they never play
nothing man i'm the first one you're
like a surprise huh yeah you know and
then my brother started to to to do a
mixed martial arts too oh he's a
professional too but it's like not like
a real
job for him it's just like he wants he
go to the gym
and do the exercise and everything
and if he
has the opportunity to fight he'd do it
if not he's like okay right it's
a hobby it's a hobby for for him so yes
man again i don't know i have a nice
chin uh he hit me with his best punches
in both of these guys
i got hurt one time he was watching
last five put ice on my neck yeah man
last fight i can recognize he throw me
his best punch in the t round
and he was like a little flashbang but
i was fine
so man the possibility to the knuckle
decide was there always because a good
punch is a good punch but
but maybe you can't you guys can't do it
maybe man we have something
so something mystic between us
i don't like i mean the guy is a
horrible person but
yeah do you think he has the same
because his energy is different than
yours
that's why that's why i mean right now i
mean to me this revalry is is in the
hall of fame of the ufc right now easily
oh yeah
do you think that but where does it go
from here because it's like if there's
nowhere really for you to get like you
guys could
i feel like you guys could do this for
five more years you know i could do it
you see
uh 400
you guys are coming out there like this
moreno against figuereto 50 i don't know
man i i can i don't care i mean it's not
personal it's for me man i just want the
title man right i just want to be the
best
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one